in a world where email is crucial spam
messages play your inboxes disrupting
our digital lives but fear note a hero
emerges the email spam classifier this
intelligent system learns from past
encounters uncovering the tricks
employed by spammers deceitful subject
lines promising glitches unreasonable
low prices it's sports signs like
excessive capital letters misspellings
and suspicious URLs yet the better
designed end here spammers constantly
evolve their tactics but the email spam
classifier doesn't Flint it adapts
refining its knowledge and staying up to
date with the latest tricks every new
spam email it encounters it provides
insights enhancing its accuracy and
ensuring our protection thanks to
Dedicated minds and Ai and ml power the
fight against email spam continues the
email spam classifier stands as a
faithful Guardian a symbol of
Technologies victory over digital
adversaries it reclaims inboxes and
restores ordered to our virtual world
according to recent studies Ai and
machine learning related job postings
have increased by a staggering 344
percent in the past five years companies
across the global actively seeking
professionals who can harness the power
of data and build intelligent systems
the average salary is 150 000 in the US
and 15 lakhs per annum in India
accelerate your career in Ai and machine
learning with a comprehensive
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning gain expertise in machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision and reinforcement learning you
will receive a prestigious certificate
exclusive alumni membership and
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
by IBM with three capstones and 25 plus
industry projects using real data sets
from Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience master classes by
Purdue faculty and IBM experts and show
top-notch education simple less job
assist help you notice by Leading
companies life session Zone AI trends
like chat GPT generative Ai and
explainable AI this program course
statistics python supervised and
unsupervised learning NLP neural
networks computer vision gns kras
tensorflow and many more skills enroll
now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers
you need to keep updating your skills on
a regular basis no matter what level
you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue with that having
said hey everyone welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel but before we
dive into that don't forget to like
subscribe and share and now over to our
training experts
so hello and welcome to this new video
by simply learn email spam classifier
okay so first we will change his name
to email
fam
okay
so first what we gonna do
so first what we're gonna do we will
import some libraries then the main main
library is like num pipe and other scale
on and logistic regression algorithm and
then we will move on to this
importing of data set of spam mail and
ham mail ham is known as like which is
not a Spam okay so we will do some
categorization of spam email and ham
email
then we will split into the training
test and the testing of the data set
okay then we will transform the text
data to feature vectors that can be used
as input to the logistic regression and
then we will convert the Y train and the
white test values as integers and then
moving forward we will see the features
the model extractions and then we will
train the model using logistic
regression
and after that we will predict the
accuracy how much the training data is
giving how much the testing data is
giving and at the end we will build a
predictive system which will
tell whether a particular email is Spam
or not spam Okay cool so let's move on
to the
coding part then okay so first I will
import some major libraries like import
numpy
as any B
okay
then
numpy so number is a powerful python
library for numerical computing so it
stands for numerical Python and provides
support for efficient array operations
and mathematical function linear algebra
random number generation and more with
numpy you can work with the
multi-dimensional array known as ND
arrays and these arrays are highly
optimized for performance and allow you
to perform mathematical and logical
operations on large data set efficiently
so numpy provides a wide range of
function and methods to manipulate and
analyze these arrays
and the second one is
import
us
as PD
okay
PDN and
we don't want to write again and again
pandas and numpy
so what is pandas
so pandas is a powerful python Library
used for data manipulation
and Analysis it provides easy to use
data structure and data analysis tool
making it essential tool for working
with structured data
so the third third one is psychic
learning
okay so I will add here from
from
the scale on dot model
selection
port
train
test
okay
so what is SQL and model selection and
the trend test split
so Escalon or scikit-learn is a popular
python library for machine learning it
provides a wide range of tools and
algorithms for various machine learning
tasks including classification
regression
and that clustering dimensional
reduction and the model evaluation okay
and this strain test split this one
so the train times split function is a
utility in scikit-learn that helps in
splitting the data set into training and
the testing subset later we will split
the data into training and adjusting so
this function is commonly used in
machine learning tasks to assess the
performance of a model on unseen data
okay so move on
to the next algorithm
we will write from
right here
from
Escalon
Dot
feature
extraction
Dot
text import
t f ID
vectorizer
okay so what is tfid vectorizer
so TF ID vectorizer is nothing is a
feature of extraction technique commonly
used in natural language processing NLP
and text mining tasks so it is a part of
scikit-learn library in Python so TF ID
vectorizer transform a collection of
text documents into a numerical
representation that machine learning
algorithm can work with
okay
so move on to we will
import from
Escalon
dot linear
model
both
logistic
regression
okay
so what is logistic regression
so logistic regression is a popular
classification algorithm used in machine
learning it is a part of the
scikit-learn library in Python logistic
learn
and the regression is suitable for
binary classification problems where the
target variable has the two classes okay
and the last we will import accuracy
score
okay
so here I will write from
dot matrix
import
accuracy
support
okay so let me tell you first what is
that curation score the accuracy score
function is a performance metric
provided by the circuit learn library in
Python it is commonly used to evaluate
the performance of a classification
model by measuring the accuracy of the
predictions okay so let me run it
okay
okay there is some error
maybe the spelling mistake
okay what I will do
I will write it again
running it again
yeah it's working
so now what I will do I will import the
data set
so I I will add here DF because to data
frame because PD dot read
underscore CSV
mean let's go data dot CSV
you can find this data set link in the
description box below okay I've done it
yeah
so let's see
the data frame
what's in it for us so as you can see
here is category then message so these
are the you know the males ham means not
spam and spam is a spam okay
those males which are not spam known as
ham
so there are two columns five five seven
two rows
so moving forward what I will do I will
convert this mail data okay to normal so
I will write here
data
equals to Raw
data equals to
DF dot where
PD dot not none
not null
is
DF
okay then
okay let me give you some spaces for the
better visual yeah
so now I will print data dot that
so what is the meaning of header head
means if you want to print the top five
lines of the particular data set it is
you can use the head and if you want to
print the last
five rows of the data set so you can use
the tail instead if you will write here
instead of giving it blank then run it
so it will give you the top 10 rows of
the particular data set okay so these
are the spam mail this hand mails so
later on what we will do we will
train this data set using this
particular
data set
okay
so let's move on to
and see the info
okay so data dot info
so info you can see there are columns
this null null count this data type so
there are two columns like category and
the message and the particular rows are
the 5572 on the both and the data type
is object
okay see the memory uses and you can see
everything
and there is one more you can see that
it shape
is 5572 comma two this these are the
rows and these are the columns two
columns and 5570 rows
okay so now what I will do I will assign
the category to spam
M and ham mail okay so what I will do
here
I will write here data Dot
Loc
then
data
versus category
equals equals to
Pam
comma
category
okay comma
question 0.
so if the 0 will show it is known as the
spam and if one will show it is known as
the handmade okay I will write here did
dot dot
OC location and data
category
equals equals to
have
than
category
will be
one
okay then let me run it okay it's
running smoothly so I will write here x
equals to data
[Music]
message
and the Y value will be
then category
okay then let me
run it
so now what I will do first
so now what I will do I will write a
print
these are only the is
category
print
y
so now as you can see 1 1 0 1 1 0 so
here 0 means
what is the zero means zero means spam
and the one means it's ham Mill okay
so moving forward what I will do I will
split this data set into testing and the
training okay so I will write here x
strain
this is the most important part
and the X test
okay
then y train
then y test
okay because your train
test
split
X comma y
comma
that size
equals to
0.2
then
random
okay random state
equals to
three
okay
I will write it
so this is X
train for the training set and X test is
the testing okay then the same way you
know the what is the X and Y here
and here we are splitting using train
test split then xoma y test size is
equal to 0.2
okay 0.2 means
it will be 80 and 20 and 80 will be
raining and the testing will be 20 okay
we will train data 80 of data using this
data set will be trained
and for the test the 20 will tell
okay the random State equals to three
and the random state is a hyper
parameters used to control any such
Randomness involved in machine learning
model to get consistent result okay when
splitting a data set splitting a node in
a decision tree or a you know logistic
regression analyzing centroid is
clustering takes place so that is why
we use random straight okay so let me
run it
it's working fine
so now I will show print
x dot shape
okay then print
X
underscore train
dot ship
I will show you about the I'm talking
about the test size the print
X underscore test dot shape
now see carefully
so as you can see
total rows are five five seven two
total row of 80 percent is four four
five seven or else you can calculate and
the twenty percent is for the testing is
the one triple one five
same goes for the Y
so moving forward okay let me show you
for the Y also so I will copy paste it
here
so it's
y
same goes for the Y also
okay
so now what I will do here I will
transform the text data to feature
vectors that can be used as input to the
logistic regression
so
feature
extraction
question
t 5D
vectorizer
where the minimum
towards
okay stop words
equals to
English
and
lowercase
okay here I am transforming the test
data to the feature vector
and
so here
so this is a feature extraction we are
using TF for D vectorizer okay we have
import here as you can see for the
feature extraction of the text
and this is the minimum difference equal
to 1 and then what is the stop word the
stop words are the English words which
does not add much meaning to the
sentence they can safely be ignored
without sacrificing the meaning of the
center
okay like for example you can see the
words like the he have such words
already computerized and the capture
this is a corpus name and the chords
okay and this lowercase equals to two
true
so here I will write X strain
just
question
feature
protection
Dot
fit
transform
absence
X underscore test
features
extraction
dot transform
to the X test
okay
yeah so moving forward I will convert y
train and Y test values as an integer
because they are 0 1 0 and 0. train
equals to y
train
dot as type
in
okay then why test
it
so okay
so that is the spelling mistake
we'll copy from here
paste it here
okay
download it
why test it is
yeah it's sunny
so now what I will do I will print
extreme
train
as you can see
the X strain
so these are the messages
if I will print
X strain
features
see extend features
but then you can see
so these are the features
accuracy okay this is zero zero zero
means spam one one means M okay
so moving forward what I will do I will
now the Train the model OKAY logistic
relation so I will write a model equals
to
okay logistic
regression
so now we will you know train the model
so here I will write
model
equals to
logistic
regression
okay so we don't want to write again and
again again and again logistic reaction
so I am here assigning model to it
so let me run it
so here I will train the logistic
regression model with the training data
so here I will write model dot fit
extreme
features
White
okay here we are training the logistic
regression model with the training data
let me run it
and it's running
so moving forward we will uh do the
evaluating of the training model train
model and the prediction of the training
data so for that I will already have
prediction
on
training
data model Dot
predict
okay next string
features
okay
then I will write here accuracy
training data equals to
accuracy
over
y train
comma prediction okay I will write from
here
foreign
so now we will see the prediction so
I'll write here prediction
or simply I will like print
accuracy on training
data
comma
okay I will copy it leave it accuracy
come on
training
data okay let me run this so as you can
see accuracy on training data is 0.96
means almost 97 percent which is not bad
very very good okay we will see print
okay now we have to do for the testing
data this is for the training data and
let's see the accuracy for the testing
data so for that
I would like same prediction
test
equals to model dot predict
X test
features
on
test data
equals to accuracy
score
then why test
ification
on
test data
okay
accuracy score
so here I will write print
the accuracy on test data
radical accuracy
or
test data
okay
so as you can see the
accuracy on test data is almost same as
the training data okay almost 95 percent
97 sorry
so now what we will do we will break a
predictive system now Okay so
I will write here
like
input
okay you have to input the mail here
that
okay we will input later and we will now
write the line for the convert text to
feature Vector so for that I will write
here input
data
features pursue
feature
instruction
dot transform
okay
okay this is a function so I will write
here input
your
three
no
okay
so here we will make the prediction
okay I will write the prediction
model Dot
dot predict
input
data
features
okay
so I have some spam mails
with myself
so I will try to copy them
and let's see
okay
I have some mail so I will copy it
and I will paste it here
okay this is the second time we have
tried to contact you you have won this
this these type of mail service spam
actually
like you also know
so
I will try to run it
let me run it
okay forward to right brain
print
predictions
so zero so here as you can see
already 0 means spam
okay so this is a spam Mill actually
this is a spammal so okay wait let me
write here if
prediction
showing zero
equals equals to true
then
print
printed to
have milk
and
as
print
spam
okay
the prediction will be zero
is not equals to 1. okay so it will show
the ham male or else the spam mail very
simple pretty simple
see Zero spam mail okay I will try to
put it put here
one hand mail
okay
let me copy it paste it here
let me delete this quickly
okay let me run this
so it is showing ham Mill means not spam
so quickly let me run one more spam mail
okay
copy this
and paste it here
you can try with your own like own email
to God
okay so let me run this so it is a spam
mail okay see you can see you have been
selected to stay the marketing okay see
in so these type of mails are like you
know these and
the vouchers this type of mails are
known as the spam mail see holiday value
this dial this and this
okay so here we are we have done with
our email spam classifier
as you can see if you want this code
so you can
comment down below
so with this we have come to end of this
video I hope you found this video
informative and interesting if you like
this video give some a thumbs up and
share it with your friends also if you
have any question about this video
please feel free to ask in the comment
section or you want this code you can
comment down the phone same our team
will get back to you as soon as possible
and the course is covered in this video
will be provided in the description box
do check them out too okay so till then
thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign